un
autre panel ce soir stéphanie grammond
alec castonguay et hélène buzzetti
bonsoir à vous trois bonsoir mais
commençons par des infirmières alec j'ai
entendu votre entrevue sur les ondes de
la radio de radio canada avec la même et
vidic man madame montaut
le discours a pas vraiment changé c'est
qu'on comprend vraiment qu'il ya une
espèce de cristallisation c'est à dire
que les infirmières tiennent vraiment
faim les déléguées syndicales chaîne
vraiment à ce que celles qui sont
libérés une fois par semaine et accès
aux fameuses primes ne pourrait tirer
celle qui ont quitté le service public à
revenir et on comprend qu'il ya vraiment
un enjeu avec l'ancienneté parce qu'on
se dit si on remet des conditions
intéressantes pour celles qui ont quitté
nécessairement celles qui sont restées
qui vont en payer le prix est ce que
vous voyez une résolution une façon de
d'arriver à une entente dans le
gouvernement et les syndicats
je pense que la question des primes pour
les délégués syndicaux lâche un peu plus
facile à régler c'est peut-être l'objet
briand qui détourne l'attention ça fait
de la bonne clip en conférence de presse
je pense que c'est assez facile à régler
cette question mais ce qui est plus
compliqué c'est le voile et des jolis
vous avez accroché sur la même partie
que moi lors de nos entrevues c'est la
question de l'ancienneté et soigne pas
véritablement de bonne ou de mauvaise
position et a dit que les deux côtés ont
des bons arguments
quand christian dubé dictée - si je
tente de convaincre des intérieurs à la
retraite ou des infirmières qui sont en
secteur privé de revenir au public je
peux pas les a renvoyés en bas de la
liste de rappel qui choisissent en
dernier dans les bacs ans qui avait
jamais de congés ils vont parvenir
jusqu'à pas capables d'en convaincre les
syndicats disent oui mais si vous faites
ça vous allez donc rétrogradé dans la
liste ceux et celles qui ont fait
l'effort de rester dans le public on
fait des heures supplémentaires
obligatoires qui ont obtenu le réseau à
bout de bras dans les dernières années
et donc vous allez faire de la place à
ceux qui dans le fond se sont sauvés
lors vous avez besoin de ramener un
excellent argument aussi du côté des
syndicats de ne pas laisser l'histoire
se produire donc ça ça va être compliqué
il faut s'asseoir il faut être capable
de trouver ça sera pas par conférences
de presse interposées
parce qu'on prend dans les médias mais
c'est clair que c'est un point
d'achoppement de 13 important dans la
stratégie de
ses fans et comment vous l'expliquez
cette sortie du ministre hier parce
qu'effectivement c'est très frontal on
se fait pas d'amis qu'on fait une sortie
comme seul non je pense que ça a été un
peu brutal et un tango ça se danse à
deux donc je ne crois pas que c'est en
faisant des sorties médiatiques comme ça
que les ministres vont arriver à ses
fins c'est sûr que c'était peut-être un
peu un calcul facile que de 10 rebonds
les représentants syndicaux de toute
façon ce pas nécessairement les gens les
plus populaires dans l'opinion publique
alors si on peut casser un peu de sucre
sur leur dos ben ça va peut-être nous
nous faire marquer des points mais mais
c'est pas comme cela qu'on va arriver à
une entente avec les infirmières et il
faut il faut négocier il faut s'asseoir
donc je pense que ça se fait pas de vin
en conférence de presse devant des
caméras et le ministe du biopôle choix
là il n'est besoin de ces infirmières
pour faire fonctionner le réseau est il
le fait des promesses il ya plusieurs
mois de rattraper des opérations que son
temps en temps c'est pas comme ce qui
est en voie d'arriver à ses fins willem
vous voyez ça comment mais vous l'avez
dit tout à l'heure dans votre entrevue
qu'il y eu quand même une joute de
relations publiques dans toute cette
affaire est clairement quand même le
ministre dubé se cherche un bouc
émissaire pour expliquer le fait que son
opération ne fonctionne pas on l'a déjà
vu avec les médecins on offre ap fort
sur les médecins qui prennent pas
suffisamment de patients là on passe aux
infirmières et comme le dit stéphanie
lol et les délégués syndicaux ne sont
pas nécessairement ceux qui récolte le
plus de popularité dans la population
alors c'est facile de marquer des points
politiques comme ça on comprend un peu
la frustration du gouvernement qui prend
mal légitime qui dans une situation
exceptionnelle cherche à trouver des
mécanismes exceptionnels des solutions
exceptionnelles qui dérogent peut-être
des cadres rigides habituel et bon
frustration du fait que ça ne débouche
pas mais je constate quand même une
certaine rigidité de part et d'autre on
parlait de l'ancienneté je pense qu'alex
à l'aide par dont le très bien expliqué
mais aussi une rigidité peut-être du
côté du gouvernement sur cette question
des congés la dc on s'absente pour une
journée de congé on perd et ça semble
tellement restrictives contre la place
qu'on y voyant pour un congé de maladie
pour un con j'ai suivi de grossesse sont
à conjuguer exhorté c est quand même
impensable
et l'on comprend bien aussi la position
sur les délégués médicaux
si on n'est même pas capable d'accorder
une prime à quelqu'un qui sape centrait
pour 2 3 suivi de grossesse imaginer
quelqu'un qui satisferait une fois par
semaine pour boursault syndicale mais on
veut passer à un autre dossier mais on
reste dans cette question de ton encore
une fois parce qu'après chose avec les
infirmières que le temps parfois un
cinglant là aujourd'hui un député
libéral marc tanguay qui s'est fait
traiter de complotiste à l'assemblée
nationale par le ministre se mangeant
des barrettes voici ce que ça a donné
est ce que le député de lafontaine ni la
pandémie monsieur le président est ce
que le député de lafontaine depuis mars
2020 est conscient qu'une pandémie
mondiale est ce que le député de
lafontaine ni cette réalité là est ce
qu'ils croient que c'est un complot est
il un complotisme monsieur le président
mais
je dire d'être plus dans les terres je
crois que mon intervention était on ne
peut plus clair ce que je veux dire mais
est ainsi je ne veux plus jamais
entendre ce terme à l'égard de quiconque
parmi des députés alors c'est peut-être
la dernière fois que vous allez entendre
mon complice comme se lancer comme une
excuse
mais il reste que il ya quand même
quelque chose de questionnable dans
c'est à dire on a l'impression que le
gouvernement legault maintenant le
moindrement qu une critique de la part
de l'opposition ils se font ramasser et
revirer comme décret là en l'occurrence
cette fois ci c'était sur l'utilisation
de l'état d'urgence sanitaire pour
permettre de gouverner par décrets
évidemment les partis d'opposition en
ont assez de soulever la question c'est
quand même l'égyptienne stephenie mais
c'est absolument légitime et je pense
que le comportement du ministre à
l'assemblée nationale cet après midi ça
avait plus l'air d'une cour de
récréation et que dans un endroit où on
exposait débattre de deux questions
importantes
et oui c'en est une question importante
l'état d'urgence
c'est quand même dans une société
démocratique
c'est quand même quelque chose qui
devrait être remis en question là on
sait que depuis un mois ou deux il ya
des allégements les gens reprennent
retourne travailler retourne à l'école
les choses rentrent dans l'ordre donc
intimement il va falloir enlever cette
cette disposition la
transparence est tout à fait légitime
n'a pas de nom de l'opposition de poser
la question et c'est pas normal qu'on
soit répondre sur ce ton là un petit mot
là dessus avec
on a la peau très sensible au
gouvernement depuis le retour en chambre
de l'automne peu importe le sujet le
soin de mettre la santé avec les
syndicats que ce soit avec les partis
d'opposition c'est un peu des habitués à
avoir des critiques dans les derniers
dans les derniers mois de la pandémie
la réalité il sait peut-être pour ça que
oui sinon j'en ai marre et d'ailleurs
qui s'est excusé disons le tout étant
aurait agi aussi fortement c'est que
pendant la première année demi de la
pandémie est tout à fait justifié
d'avoir l'état d'urgence juste et
probablement autour de septembre il y
avait des bonnes raisons d'avoir des
contrats sans appel d'offres les
conventions collectives dans le domaine
de la santé pouvoir réorganiser le
réseau à l'abri des conventions
collectives depuis septembre c'est de
moins en moins justifiable les partis
d'opposition augmente la pression puis
c'est ce qui agace le gouvernement dès
la semaine prochaine on va danser qui on
voit chanter dans des cas la haute île à
la fin ça fait pas très étonnant
d'urgence le disons le comme ça on peut
certainement être capable de moduler la
certaines des dispositions pour être
capable de se priver cet état d'urgence
le sens que tout s'effondre le
gouvernement dit quand les jeunes les 5
à 11 ans vont être vaccinés ont relevé
les notes de classe adoptée en janvier
mais c'est clair que ça agace le
gouvernement l'a fait partie de ces
temps ci sur la vaccination des jeunes
encore faut-il que les parents et y
adhèrent encore faut il que les gens
soient bel et bien vécu il ya beaucoup
d'étapes encore là demain
beaucoup de critiques envers le
gouvernement de la caq ces temps ci on
le voit que j'accuse et des trous
vindicatif d'être trop autoritaire en
fait c'est vraiment des mots qui
reviennent très très souvent on rentre
quand même dans une année électorale
est-ce que la cac devrait avoir un peu
plus de prudence dans son ton sa manière
avec les partis d'opposition
j'ai écouté il tellement la cac est
tellement populaire que je ne la vois
pas très très menacé en ce moment mais
encore que l'élection c'est dans un an
mais de manière générale ce qui est
agaçant et j'élargis rémois le
commentaire pas seulement à la caq mais
c'était cette espèce d'unanimisme qui
est exigé la dans le contexte sanitaire
c'est comme s'il n'était plus possible
d'avoir un discours alternatif
légèrement différent et moi je fais même
le lien avec la question la question de
la vaccination obligatoire et on
entendra peut-être un peu plus tard tout
à l'heure à ottawa où c'est vraiment
d'actualité et il n'est comme plus
possible dans le contexte d'apporter de
quelconques nuances tout doit être ou
bien noir ou bien blanc mais surtout
blanc et sinon vous êtes dans le même
panier que un complotiste c'est un peu
agaçant et ça nous fait perdre quand
même une nuance importante dans des baux
public et sa bonne faire passer à côté
peut-être de certains enjeux qui sont
pertinents sur la question de la
vaccination obligatoire notamment leur
milieu de travail ça soulève des
questions très importantes et ce comme
si on n'avait plus le droit d'en parler
parce que tout de suite on est étiquetté
le comme étant un fou furieux
essentiellement donc on a perdu les
nuances finalement bon on va parler de
la semaine fédérale maintenant parce que
l'oci se passe des choses en fait tous
les partis sont en train de se préparer
pour la rentrée parlementaire officiel
le 22 novembre maintenant d'abord des
conservateurs on essaie de se
réorganiser ils ont dévoilé cette
semaine leur cabinet fantôme yann
lavallez lancé le bal là dessus parce
que la critique qui revient ou en fait
une observation jugerait qui revient
c'est dans le cabinet fantôme c'est des
critiques finalement à quintiq de
différents fonctionnaires mais le plus
de critiques qui administre en réalité
alors parce que c'est quoi le but c'est
de faire plaisir à tout le monde c'est
quoi ben oui un peu de ça donc il ya
beaucoup de critiques mais aussi des
critiques adjoint alors une liste
presque aussi long que ça fait vraiment
beaucoup de monde qu'on veut c'est une
façon de mettre en vedette mettre en
évidence nous députés de d'améliorer
leur profil notamment
you une nomination quand même que je
trouve assez intéressante celle de
michel revol albertaine aux ressources
naturelles ça c'est quand même un choix
particulier parce que madame ron paul et
les traits
affirmative sur les questions du pétrole
de protéger sa promesse elle avait été
l'instigatrice de cette belle
déclaration de la déclaration du bison
si on peut traduire pour vraiment faire
protéger sa province alors et madame
rapport quelqu'un de très affirmative
ça risque de camper encore une fois le
parti conservateur comme le protecteur
de l'alberta et sol lorsque l'on cherche
à faire des gains en ontario puis au
québec c'est pas nécessairement ce qui
est le plus gagne ce qu'on est aussi
c'est le retour elec d'aller rayess
comme lieutenant politique la place de
richard martel richard mattel
rappelons-nous le qui était celui qui
avait appuyé la course à la chefferie et
venez tôt là on considère finalement
probablement coûté on n'a pas eu les
résultats escomptés manifesteront québec
on a mis aussi elle a compté de gérard
deltell alors lui aussi il reste le
leader parlementaire qu'est ce que vous
pensez ces choix là qu'est ce que ça
indique je pense que c'est un excellent
choix des vélos mais chez martell on le
mit dans cette position là parce qu'il
avait été l'un des premiers appuis de
rennes aux tours mais ça n'aurait pas
nécessairement
aller reyes au contraire avait réussi
lors d'élections précédentes même si ça
s'était soldée par le même résultat ou
indochine que seraient nos taux avait
une brochette de candidats de très
grande qualité malgré qu'il avait en mai
contre courant pour lire exulter c'est
un vrai organisateur alain reyes il
parle bien dans les médias c'est un bon
communicateur il tout d'un bon
lieutenant alors c'était déjà un peu
spécial de lui retirer ça mais on
comprenait le claj août internes avaient
avaient pesé dans la balance mais de
leur ramener comme ça je pense qu'il ya
de l'humilité la chaire une auto il a
pris la bonne décision pour les
conserves au matin du québec ça va être
plus efficace d'avoir à les reyes dans
ce post mais monsieur martel leurs
connaissances peut-être que ce prologue
j'ai tu peux être le plus efficace
commun une place monsieur martel dans le
cabinet fantôme faut noter là il n'a pas
été oublié au nonce au critique aux
finances on ramène pierre poilievre le
tout un style stéphanie monsieur
poilievre on peut pas le manquer quand
il parle du en chambre
oui c'est ça mais moi je me vengerai à
dire sur le cabinet fantôme de monsieur
au touquet en a moins autant de
personnes c'est peut-être la preuve que
justement il n'y a de la difficulté à
faire des choix iliad a de la difficulté
à se commettre il veut faire plaisir à
tout le monde et puis comme son parti
est extrêmement divisé ça nous amène
tout le temps dans une situation où on
ne sait pas quelle adresse il loge et
puis un bon jour il va falloir qui est
et qui présente le une vision auclair
est unique parce qu'autrement le
lancement va jamais collé mais le com
est présenté comme en dire un peu plus
de clarté en écartant son cabinet
fantôme la députée marie-line gladu
c'est quand même un geste important
parce que maintenant donc la duel avait
dit des choses sur la colline le quai
les scandaliser bien des gens ce n'est
pas plus grave que d'autres maladies est
ch'ti robe on s est excusé par la suite
elle dit que c'est important de faire la
promotion du vaccin bref elle tient
complètement non discours mais ceci dit
et quand même une sorte de punition
hélène par son coin de son expulsion ce
cabinet mais sans angoisse quand même un
message non il en garde pour tous les
autres
oui on peut le voir comme ça quoi que je
dois quand même dire que c'est un peu
dommage parce que madame delà du oui
elle a eu ce commentaire malheureux
keller ratti retirer rapidement et je
pense qu'à essayer de faire une
comparaison plate historique cocasses et
boiteuse mais m'bia d'une épaule un
éléments extrémistes le du caucus
conservateur c'est quelqu'un d'assez
pose est quelqu'un de très agréable
d'une bonne tête sur les épaules et
avait même songé très brièvement à se
porter candidate à la succession
d'indochine et ce fameux caucus lequel
veut créer bon certains le présentent ça
comme peut-être un caucus des anti
vaccination est peut-être que ça
deviendra effectivement le repère des
députés non vaccinés et où des députés
qui ne croient pas à la vaccination mais
le but avoué on verra si c'est ce qui
arrive mais le but avoué pour revenir
sur ce que je disais tout à l'heure de
faire un peu une recherche sur les
conséquences de la vaccination
obligatoire dans le milieu de travail
sur les citoyens et c'est quand même pas
inintéressant
on peut se poser la question si de même
atteint tous les employeurs du canada
exigeait la vaccination est ce que ça
voudrait donc dire qu'il n'y existe plus
de libre choix et que les gens qui ont
des des réticences même si on les
condamne envers la vaccination n'ont
plus le droit de travailler c'est quand
même une question qui n'aurait pas été
étudiées et si le comité qu'elle entend
créer madame il a dû se limite à ça ça
peut avoir une vertu mais politiquement
c'est clair que ça nuit au conservateur
ça permet aux adhère fall des étiquettes
et comme étant des hurluberlus qui ne
croit pas à la science on n'est pas une
rentrée non seulement facile de
promotion autour avec un dernier mot
maintenant mais parlons du bloc
québécois y avait un point de presse de
leur chef aujourd'hui monsieur blanchet
qui a présenté ses priorités on sait
qu'il ya eu des conversations entre le
npd parti libéral pour essayer de se
maintenir finalement pas basculer une
élection de retrouver le bloc a pas eu
droit ce genre de conversation mais
monsieur manchette dire non nous on va
être un incontournable vous allez voir
est ce qu'il ya vraiment un
contournement folle c'est quoi la fois
le fond d'histoire
sont importants mais ne sont pas
incontournables dans la mesure où justin
trudeau peut faire des alliances
ponctuelles avec le npd donc contourner
le bloc québécois même pas que le parti
conservateur même si c'est un peu contre
nature est parfois avec le bloc
québécois moi je crois pas trop trop
pour parler d'alliance le formel ou
informel entre les libéraux plein [ __ ]
probablement qu'on se bat pour connaître
un peu les priorités de chacun pour le
discours du trône est capable d'avoir un
plan de marche qui se tient mais on n'a
pas besoin je les libéraux de faire de
concessions on a le gros bout du bâton
personne le prenant élections pas plus
le bloc le npd que les conservateurs la
situation actuelle donc oui je pense que
le bloc est un joueur important il était
incontournable passe aussi le sco dit
françois blanchet mais en réalité ils
vont être importants sur certains enjeux
sur d'autres libéraux vont s'appuyer
ailleurs dont je pense pas car beaucoup
de différences en termes de dynamique
par rapport au précédent par heymans
expliqué au personnel goût de retourner
en élections bon ça au moins c'est enfin
là dessus pour maintenant on peut je
vais prouver de l'avenir bon mais c'est
fini avec hélène merci beaucoup bonne
soirée au revoir mais c'est pour voir
nos émissions nantes et rendez vous sur
la chaîne i see her dit